All right, welcome everybody to today's zoom call. It is
Monday
and
Everybody has got their questions and a bunch of questions came in. So let's jump in it right away and then please chat in any other questions
Reminder to look at the members only site for all announcements
And please ask your questions through there everybody did also reminder that
You get all of these courses should you want to you know
Research more stuff about your genes about detoxification about line about the right. That's the frequency healing course
These are all free to you to use and remember it is your same user name and password that you use for the member site to access all the courses
All right first question
A month ago my husband and I moved to a rural area in Missouri and last week we found out that this country is highly contaminated with lead and other heavy metals because of
90 in the past our home is about a hundred feet away from a dusty gravel road that the neighbors repair twice a year with gravel from the area
This county has a large number of children with high levels of lead in their blood
There's a program for the government for residential remediation if lead levels in soil are about 400 parts per million and
For the well water if levels are high
Don't provide filters. This is a
Very common scenario for more people than you think a lot of people are in situations where there is contamination and they just don't even know
Check with your county about possible contaminations and I recommend that anybody was well water get there well checked on a regular basis as well
So definitely
Check with it now if this is the case to this person email their message if
If this is the case where you have high levels of heavy metals and you you know, maybe you don't have them in your body now
But you're wanting to garden you're wanting to be able to choose your property
Then you definitely
Want to be taking a key later. So that's where what would be helpful for everybody is to go back and get
Get on this course is the seven phases of detoxification because in that I talk about
Supporting all your pathways. So you get rid of heavy metals through your
Through your liver pathways. So you need to support those pathways
And that's why we did a whole genetic workup and recommend that on people because it's so beneficial to help support your phase wanted phase two pathways
But there's seven phases of
Explication so you want to be looking at supporting all those pathways. It's very important. So if you're doing everything to support
Let's say you're pond one pathway
But your constipated, you know, you know, you're really could possibly be hurting yourself. So
Download my book the seven phases of detoxification. You can read that. It's short. It's less than a hundred pages
Get out of the course and follow through some of that information to better understand the seven phase of detoxification because this is a perfect example of the poisonous world that we live in so
You know
Best to
Do as much as possible to
Through vet toxicification instead of having to be detoxed something that's in your body already. I have been short of breath since
COVID and pneumonia if you have any ideas
I was looking at the article from doctor McCola that you posted and wondering about that if this is what you would suggest
Where would I get the hydrogen peroxide that is a good quality also you added the astral clear to my protocol how many a day
Thank you, so
I can't remember who it is that asked this question, but I shouldn't put on how many a day of the astral clear
So I look at that go back and look at who posted this question
But definitely the any time you have issues with lung issues breathing issues
using
Protocol that I put up on the site, okay, it's on the homepage see the PDF from doctor McCola the recipe for debilizing the hydrogen peroxide to help heal the lungs
That's where would you get the hydrogen peroxide you just 3% hydrogen peroxide that you would get in 80 for the sea in target that haven't no marketing thing like that
You just have to get a debilizer and
Unfortunately during COVID debilizers were very helpful so people so
To say this, but it's not a conspiracy theory. They were pulled off the stores. You could even find a bit of stores
You could still get them on Amazon, so make sure you get the debilizer
The debilizers are great to use for any kind of lung issues because you're getting whatever nutrient right into your lungs, so it's very good
In the past few days, I've had this situation where I wait where I stand up
Whatever I stand up I get dizzy the dizziness varies from mild to blacky note
What could I do to correct this when that is not good?
So if you're blacky note when you're standing up or even if you're getting dizzy when you're standing up
We kind of got to go through a differential diagnosis here
So your blood pressure should raise about 12 about 10 to 20 points when you just rise from a sitting position that is actually from
Neurological reflex and a hormonal reflex to be able to pump blood to your head
So if a person has low blood pressure, this can be happening
So why would they get low blood pressure? Well, they could have low blood pressure because if they look at their CBC
There they have low red blood cells and low hemoglobin. So that's the most common reason for that is low hemoglobin
You could have blockage to the carotid artery feeding the head also, so that's a possibility too
Could have adrenal insufficiency. That's a possibility because the hormonal connection that raises your blood pressure is
created in your adrenal glands
I would make sure you get a CBC get into your doctor and get a CBC in a complete metabolic panel to see where
Your hemoglobin's at where your red blood cells are at
And then in the meantime, you have to just take every precaution
You got to go really really slow allow blood to get to your head before you start moving forward
So that is the most common cause of dizziness black you know
Upon standing is is because you're not getting enough and quick enough
profusion of blood into your arteries in your brain
So it's a protective measure of your body
For you to tend up with
You know
Attack on the brain
I was just told that my CT scan revealed some small growth in my tumor and my CA 19
Number went back up to triple digits low 100s
This was after being on a chemo holiday
But also sticky to my protocol. We don't want to go back on chemo
What should my next steps be?
Since the news I've taken honey
Only my bud would protocol and citrus foods out of my juicing diet
As I am afraid the sugar may be feeding my cancer
Now I'm only using meat apples, celery, carrots
And plant-paste or gain protein as my main diet and any other suggestions
Um other than getting another cheek swab to see if we need to tweak your protocol
Um, I think you're making some good choices. They've been okay
Well, if it could be sugar that may be feeding my cancer right now
Then taking as much of that all of my diet is that's that's a good choice
I get cannot tell you to not to do chemo or to do chemo
That's a choice that you're going to have to make
Um if it's solely small growth maybe you know, just let's just reason together
Maybe it's like okay, well how small if it's only a few millimeters gross is that
It did the normal range of error when you're reading a test
Um, that's a question to ask your oncologist
Uh, maybe say you know another thing would be that's you know, I'm still feeling well you have to
guide some of the objective findings and balance them with subjective findings as well
So you have to balance these things together
I'm still feeling really well. I don't have any other signs or symptoms
Um, maybe stay the course make these small changes
As you see phantom get another scan to see how
Those are doing in another two or one for tests more recent, you know more
It in the more recent future like sooner
As someone with pancreatic cancer am I supposed to be using the grounding mat under my feet when using the rifle sleeping
No, so you only use the grounding mat with the foot bath detox. That's my recommendation. You only use the grounding mat
When you're using the foot bath detoxification and you're putting it on your back
Where you're up or back you're sitting on it something like that to give the frequencies to come through
I've heard conflicting messages about being able to do the budway protocol
While my overall protocol says I shouldn't have dairy
Um, yes, I gave you permission this person because I wrote this permission to do the budway some people I'll say don't do the budway
Um, if dairy is a main driver, sometimes I'll say not to there's benefits to doing the budway
I know budwig um says that you know adding
Uh the fact to the dairy changes the dairy
Well, no, it doesn't it doesn't change the the fact that dairy still has growth factors in it because it is
Then for baby cows. So it uh
But
And it still has k seeded and if we have k seed
food sensitivity as well, too. So there are some people that shouldn't some people that it's okay for
um
Everybody's just different for you. You said that was okay to do that
I haven't used any testosterone cream one click the day one click is 0.25 milliliters
And it's 200 milligrams per milliliters. So probably about 50 milligrams per day
Is this still okay to use that was originally using it to protect my heart not sure
If using any exogenous hormones is okay with cancer. Well it really depends on the cancer. So really
um
Testosterone cream would not be okay for prostate cancer
Um, I would say no. I know the person who asked this question and they don't have to uh prostate cancer. So
uh
Testosterone cream would probably would also be a no
If this was a female and asking uh, and they have
breast cancer or ovarian cancer or uterine cancer
Even if it's not ER PR or or to positive still testosterone because women do take testosterone for those reasons
Still testosterone excess testosterone will be stored in the fat cells and through
Uh the aromatase enzymes will aromatize
Into different estrogens um, so if you don't have a cancer that has anything to do with um four modes
Uh, being a part of its growth or hindering apoptosis maybe a better way to say it
Then it's fine to take um core modes. It's not an issue to take thyroid dental deformities
So in this case for you you'd be fine. You can keep taking that. It should not be an issue
I've only had the right for two weeks
Is there a rule of thumb on how quickly to expect the difference of tumor size?
Does it matter how larger tumors were to begin with?
Did the lymph nodes usually get smaller before or after the main tumors do not looking for definitive answers or promises
But just an average patients experience. We just have no idea what to expect at all
Or what realistic timeframe for evaluating progress
Should be um, I tell people to usually give it three months um to see how things are going
And the problem with measuring progress with the right machine is it's um, you just don't know it's it's with anything
It's not just with the right machine. Let's say if you're doing chemo
And okay, let's say you have a breast tumor that's um, you know
You know two centimeters round and three months after doing chemo the breast tumors
Three centimeters round. Well, it's the chemo's not working. Well
We can't really definitively say that because if you did it through chemo
Could the breast tumor be six centimeters round? We just don't know there's too many
too many um variables that that that play into it. So we just don't know
Um, doesn't mean that maybe you should think about doing something
Different also or in addition to the chemo if it's larger after three months. Yes. I would say yes
It's still not moving in the direction that we want to at the speed that we wanted to
So that's how re-evaluations should be made that's reasonable. It's what your oncologist would tell you too. So if there's
Um, if there's no change in size. Let's say at breast tumors two centimeters
Large and three months to measure to get it still two centimeters large
um
Well, then you know, it's basically stop to grow. We which is huge win. So
At tumor doesn't always have to shrink in size for you to be winning the battle cancer
Tumor has to really stop growing. We wanted to stop acting like a cancer meeting what is the definition of cancer?
It's in a rapid replication phase and if it isn't growing it's the same size after two months
Well, technically, it's not in rapid replication anymore. So or at least your body is destroyed
It as fast as it speed replicated. So hey, you're winning the war
um, so the only um caveat to that would be as if it's in a lumen that's affecting, you know
Let's say if it's in your colon and it's you know the size of a lebed and it's blocking
feces move it then, you know, we still need to do something else. We can't leave it that size
But if it stopped growing, that's huge real. So that's how we measure
um, effectiveness of anything. So um, that we kind of put the breaks out of the growth process as much as possible
I'm not trying uh, I am trying not to go too nuts with the low histamine diet. Yes, because we described that a lot
But I don't want to make my situation worse either of supposed to stay away from green tea
But I see a few less supplements have green tea extract
So understand green tea extract does not have histamines in it. It's the green tea
drinking green tea to have histamines in it. So I don't worry about that. It's eating ground meat
um, really not allowed um, so I don't know your protocol per se so your protocol says no red meat
Then yeah, that's not allowed but it does not say let's say it says no
Pork that you can certainly have some ground meat. So typically
grow turkey or grow beef is what you would think of or grow bison or something
When you think of ground meat at least that's what I think
I read that to eat leftovers um, oh, so ground meat is talking about histamine content. So um, yes
Yes, yeah, I would say meat is your least issue with histamine
leftovers are still not as important but the longer a food sits
um, uh
The less fresh it is, the more histamine content it's gonna have
So understand if I'm gonna make some avocado or let's say I'm gonna make some asparagus
And I have leftovers and I get to eat some asparagus tomorrow. Well, just about everything has histamine in it to some degree
So my asparagus fresh doesn't really have that much histamine in it
But my leftovers are gonna have more histamine
It's still not enough to be concerned with so it depends on what your leftovers are
um
So as long as they're frozen immediately
So yes, if your leftovers are frozen immediately and then you're heating them up
You're gonna have less histamine in it. I also read not to
Even completely saw a meat before cooking it. So understand there's a difference between a person who has
serious histamine reactions
um, and
Will we're trying to reduce histamine as a as a possible fuel source of cancer. So just balance that out
Seems like a lot of rules. Yes, and depending on what website you look at there's different rules
And the reason is is that you could even see websites that have food
Shards that say to completely different things and it's because it when you test the food
It depends on how fresh that food was it depends on the source that food. There's so many variables with histamine
It's really that's why you just tried to do a lower histamine diet
You you can't be perfect with histamine. It's not possible. It's just the study impossible
Uh, so I wasn't given DAO enzyme supplement just the histamine scavenger
So is that a clue as how impactful histamines are the health this time? Yes, typically
We don't use the DAO enzyme
uh, unless a person has serious histamine issues and that's a different
Uh, they might not even have cancer. They can have serious histamine issues that the DAO enzyme can be beneficial to calm down the inflammation
That's in the gut and it has to be that's in the gut
histamine scavenger is used not to calm down so much the histamine that's in the gut
But calm down the histamine the rest of the body the DAO enzyme for histamine does not
Traverse the gut wall so it stays within the movement of the gut that helps break down histamine
Just in the gut
All right
First off, P and I can't stop thinking of you
AJ and your family my first quote to all of you my dad had leukemia so this hits
Our whole mind
Thank you for that second. I believe
I'm experiencing my first healing crisis which has come out of nowhere
I'm doing my best to get through it
But it's bringing it up old symptoms and bone and side metastasis which is limited by ability to walk
Just like two years ago
I read on the first reaction and I am in the process
Of doing coffee animals to help me get through admittedly. This is my first borrower with the enemies
I don't really have a question more of whether you're a nice current state
You please call me to help coach through this so
Call us please and schedule a appointment with me if you want
And I can help you
Whatever you wish you so just give you just give the clinic
Call and schedule a time
Okay, some questions from the chat here
my genetic says
Phase two pondwood assist but I don't
But I see there are two different ones
So the phase two and the pondwood assist are the same product
We private labeled the pondwood assist from the facial health products is our phase two
So it helps match and
With people that are just doing our detoxification course
So they can understand otherwise if you're just doing the detoxification course
The pondwood assist makes no sense with the label
Um for people that affect some people called say I have to order the polly product as it looks like PO and I some to some people
Which is kind of hilarious and if you know what the pondwood pathway is but for people who have no idea what the pondwood
Pathway is that's a detoxification pathway in the liver through the phase two detoxification pathway
That's why we changed the name to post a phase two
Where do I find the proper enzymes to buy from my genetic tested?
I don't see it listed in summary
So if we didn't put it in your summary then you don't necessarily need it
so
It can be beneficial and I've said over and over again in so many different blog posts that deep probably most
um
Necessary supplement for the general population
That's certainly for people with cancer but for the general population is
HCl plus digestive enzymes because that can be the start of health issues, you know
Systemic health issues in our body
That is the lack of HCl and lack of digestive enzymes because if we're not properly breaking down our fluid into its smallest particles
That in itself could be irritating to the colon damage you the colon causing leaky gut issues once you have leaky gut issues
peptides from proteins meaning particles of proteins
That don't get properly digested out to their amino acid coated in cross the gut wall who caused
Inflammation and worse case
Which happens quite frequently you develop antibodies against those peptides and now you have this tire ramped up inflammatory process in the body
Which can cause all sorts of problems
And you have ramped up inflammation in the gut which equals ramped up inflammation in the
Brain and those antibodies to food particles now you have even greater amount of inflammation when you eat that food that you have antibodies against
And it just becomes this cyclical problem towards bill of health
So taking digestive enzymes with hydrochloric acid which your meals can be very beneficial so that HClsine HCl-xym
Is a problem my favorite digestive enzyme general digestive enzymes for people because it's got HCl to help break down carbohydrates in your gut plus some digestive enzymes to help break down proteins and other things
HClsine by US enzymes would be my choice
What vitamin C IV
Be good for me
Um in general vitamin C IV are good for most people if we didn't yes for that and tell you to do that then that's got to be your choice
Um, but if we didn't test for that put that your protocol that's not necessarily what we're recommending
By heavy metal tests came back with Gantelidium
I saw that your email thank you. I took half the bottle of proteopathic drops after my MRI in August
So I can finish that up is there something else that I could do it specifically for the Gantelidium
already doing coffee animals
Soda daily, foot bath, Castro pack, alternative days if possible
Yes, you could possibly be you could possibly add pectusol C pectusol C is a good mild key later. So is um
um
IP-6 is a nice mild key later as well
um both of those won't overwhelm your liver so IP-6 that maybe three a day and pectusol C and what are two scoops a day would be good
uh imprison調 oversee that does come at a capsule for two but uh it's a little bit less expensive and
the powder for you good if you already needed it taking a smoothie that it's easier to throw
in mind. I'm getting foot and shed uh rrate scranps ramps for over a month uh
primarily for waking hours. So foot and lower leg cramping, the first thing you think of is
mineral deficiency can also be iron deficiency. So make sure you get a CVC to make sure what
your red blood cells at and what your hemoglobin is at. That would be proper
medical attention there. If it is a mineral deficiency then you think of magnesium. If you're
if you're at all constipated that I would have magnesium. If it's a mineral other general
mineral deficiency I would look at clear multiband plus. Do the lymph nodes typically go back to normal
before or after other tumor shrink. It's just varies completely. And remember your tumors might not
shrink your relips bills like that. Ever go back to normal or desire is just to get them to stop
rowing. So it's just it's varying. Some people's tumors start to shrink and just stop and some people's
lymph nodes go back to normal. Usually those go back to if there's a bit of any shrinkage usually
if they're first. That's just that's just a general. I'm a little concerned because I have a
lymph node under my arm getting bigger in the last three weeks or so. I couldn't feel it before.
But only I'm using it right for a couple of weeks. One of the tumors is large five centimeters. So
not sure I'll notice when it gets starts shrinking. That's what's good to possibly get
a baseline ultrasound. So you can get another ultrasound and see because it's a very
known invasive way to check size if it's hard to palpate. And usually we'll get that through a local
practitioner pretty easy too. The rest tumors typically break the skin. I don't know what to do if
that happens. Well, I wouldn't say anything's typical of breast tumors, but you want them to come
towards the surface. You don't want them to go back towards the chest wall. So if they're coming towards
the surface that's usually a much better thing by everybody's expectation. If it does break the skin
or it's getting close to breaking the skin, then you have some other choices to make.
An oncologist would probably recommend chemotherapy to try to shrink it. We've had patients
allow the tumors to come through the skin so that they can use topicals, but that opens up a
whole other can of worms. And it's not easy by any stretch of the imagination. But it's not necessarily,
you know, any type of complete fix with some people. So just make sure you communicate with me
exactly what's going on if things are changing. Any other questions? Nothing else? Well, then we'll end
for the day. Thank you for asking the questions on the member site. I appreciate it. Continue to do
that. And we will talk again on Wednesday. All right, bye to everybody. Know that I prayed for all of you.
And just ask that you continue to pray for Anne and AJ, especially
and I'll talk to Anne about what updates I can post on this site. So thank you for that.
We will know that they cherish your frames. So please continue to pray. All right, thanks so much. Bye-bye.